from August 1977 to September 1978 a
series of events took place which
stunned the nation and have subsequently
become one of the world's miss
shockingly infamous altar guys faces
hey everybody welcome to episode 12 this
is episode 12 right yeah of the 13
o'clock podcast we have the computer
[ __ ] the bed over the weekend so we have
kind of a new setup hopefully it sounds
better and not worse but we'll see how
it goes
also if you hadn't noticed our audio
only version of the podcast is now on a
revamped
new network called the project
entertainment network so all of our new
episodes just the audio version will be
there instead of project I radio they're
doing that transition yeah it's a cooler
Network anyway so there's a move up it's
all good yeah it's all been so with that
housekeeping out of the way we should
get right into the topic which today is
probably one of the best-known haunting
slash poltergeist cases in the world and
it's actually the benchmark case this
this case is the case of all cases it's
the absolute best example of what
poltergeist phenomena is like I read the
book of the book about this case is
called the Enfield haunting I read the
book about it and it just is perfect so
it's a perfect case it perfectly
describes what what living through a
poltergeist episode is like yeah and if
you're actually not familiar with this
case which I'd be surprised if you
weren't but if you saw the movie the
conjuring 2 that was loosely based on
that very loosely very loosely and also
there was a there was a TV series like a
three-part miniseries produced for
British TV called the Enfield haunting a
little bit better but which was better
but well the first two episodes stuck
pretty close to the story and then the
third one just went flying right off the
rails and had people flying around it
goes bad and they added a bunch of drama
and conflict that wasn't there it wasn't
there yeah really want to know what the
Enfield poltergeist was about you have
to get dylai and playfair's book this
house is haunted and and they just
re-released it they just read published
that yeah I think they because for a
while it was out of print
I have one of the old out-of-print ones
Jenny bought it for me it was awesome
yeah it was like an old library book
yeah because it wasn't available but I
had originally read the book back in the
80s when I was in high school I think
was an 87
yeah just blew my mind it was like yeah
that's it that's that's kind of what
that's what I went through
yeah it's just that her poltergeist
episode was a lot worse than mine she
was she was she was fantastic at it well
it went on a lot longer than a long time
and it was it had a bunch of weird
phenomena that's not wasn't found in
other cases yeah which we get into that
a bit yeah but huge plug for this book
guy line playfair's the author he was
there with Morris gross when they when
they investigated the case and went on
for a long time he had cops and
newspaper people there reporters saw it
and then the name of the book is this
house is haunted and actually the way
that book was written was kind of the
inspiration for how we first wrote the
mammoth mountain poltergeist
I liked the matter-of-fact kind of setup
of the book where it wasn't really
because the book is not it really
exaggerated and then it's not hyped up
and it's just a straight account of what
was observed of what people saw what
people said they saw yeah and he
differentiates between the two yeah
those persons in that in other words
they didn't take everything for granted
this person said they saw this but we do
we don't know I didn't know or I don't
know because I didn't see it that's
happened deal yes that's the best way to
report something and the guy that read
the book was actually in and out of the
house over probably like a 18-month
period yeah god yeah guy fair guy play
fair he was in the house for a long time
with the family so he saw a lot of
things personally but he was you know
quick to report when it wasn't something
that he saw personally anyway it was
also quick to say when he didn't believe
something yeah because there are some
kind of aspects to this case that
because a lot of super skeptical people
which I am too but a lot of super
skeptical people just think none of it
was legitimate just because of a few
little yeahi tales you know they they
they go with the approach well this
person lied so therefore the whole case
isn't true right no you mean you know a
good
not necessarily a good case can have a
bunch of different people involved and
some of these people lie yeah yeah and I
even think the Warrens showed up on this
case for like a day for a day and
according to some of the people that
were on the case for a long time like
you know I believe it was grant Morris
who was a photographer for the Daily
Mirror at the time and he was one of the
first people to go investigate it he
claimed that the Warrens only showed up
for one day and that they showed up
uninvited right like they was not asked
to come down sounds like the war yeah
and that's photographer what was his
name again grandma grandma Morris got
hit in the head with some with a Lego
brick and that's what that's what made
him a believer he saw the Lego bricks
jumping around on the floor and flying
flying out of unseen directions where
there was nobody's in that corner yeah
and you know tried and he tried to catch
pictures of it but it was so quick and
so elusive that no matter where the
camera was pointed the Lego brick would
come from another direction yeah weird
yeah which is that's that's the same
kind of phenomena I saw yeah it's kind
of like it always happens out of the
corner IR behind you or it's like it
can't move something if you're in here
looking and looking directly at it and
we discovered earlier though cuz there
is there were some cases where we did
see things move and we're looking right
at it it was just weird yeah weird we
discussed a little bit of that on our
Mammoth Mountain show yeah but uh so
I'll put a link to that in here you
definitely want to get this book this
house is haunted by guyline prepared it
is very good if you like that one get
ours math Mountain poltergeist very
simple and also a Rossdale poltergeist
yeah very similar yeah so yeah similar
kind of poltergeist classes so okay so
the Enfield poltergeist case began in
1977 Enfield is in North London hmm and
the house it was the Hodgson family they
lived in a little council house now
Peggy Hodgson was the mother and she was
living in the house with her four
children who were Margaret it was 13
Janet who was 11 and probably the main
poltergeist focus Johnny who was 10 and
Billy who was 7
now the she had just undergone Peggy had
just undergone a divorce which in 1977
was still pretty unusual yeah so she was
actually a single mother and this is a
very poor family and they were very poor
yeah and apparently there was a lot of
contention between the ex-husband who
now had a new girlfriend and I think I
read that he would sometimes like come
by to see the kids and he would bring in
their friend right so there was like a
lot of tension in the in the household
which might have been what triggered off
the episode and 70s was also kind of
like a dark economic times for England
to show yeah it was economically
oppressed yeah you know there was a lot
of poverty a lot of unhappiness in the
UK the seventies yeah so you know that's
kind of what and additionally you know
the two girls were around puberty age
yeah there was justice yeah sisters so
which is a very common kind of thing
that you see in poltergeist cases they
had an older brother - he was known
hunger they hunger oh I think they had
an older brother that wasn't in the
house and a younger one that wasn't
house there's two younger ones in the
house okay maybe I haven't maybe have
cases
scratch that ain't gotten in trouble oh
maybe okay never mind okay never mind
that's not it's not the book Ria's not
relevant anywhere the book in a long
time so basically the disturbances
started in late summer of 1977 in August
and the first thing that happened as is
the case with most of these kind of
things it started very small yeah the
first thing that happened was you know
the kids had gone upstairs to bed or
whatever and they started to complain
that they were hearing shuffling noises
and that their beds were wobbling
quote-unquote wobbling whatever I think
I know what that means they kind of move
inside the cellar I didn't know they
complained to their mother about this
and their mother was just like you know
I'm tired knock that [ __ ] off
alright you damn kids go to surah so she
didn't think anything of it at first but
then the next evening Peggy the
she hears all this banging coming from
upstairs and the kids are kind of
freaking out so she goes up there to
kind of tell him to pipe down and she
sees according to her a chest of drawers
yeah a big one slide across the floor by
itself
yeah and she grabbed it and tried to
push it back to push it back where it
was and she got into a fight with this
thing perp you said yeah go yeah it's
gerotor she said it seemed like it was
trying to push itself against the door
like it was trying to trap them in the
room right okay or something she said
that's what it seemed like so um
obviously that for hitting them quite a
bit yeah and the kids panicked yes I
think that was the first thing they
actually saw move yeah because before I
think it was just the bed shaking
yeah that's shaking in sound yeah and
they also heard knocking on the walls
like it would go up and down the walls
like someone was on the other side of
the wall like running up and down
knocking on it yeah it would appear from
random places it might appear from a
ceiling or fourth floor it was you know
it's all over the place right now that
yeah so this was starting to freak him
out a little bit now Peggy went over to
their neighbor's house yeah it didn't
freak him out a little bit it put him in
a panic yeah let's just call it for what
it is I was easy understand yeah you
want to say she panicked and she ran
from the house and tried to get help
from the neighbors yeah the neighbors
were the Nottingham's yeah and Vic
Nottingham big burly dude you can see
him on their documentaries about this
and you can see him on there talking
about what he witnessed and he kind of
came over there big old construction
worker yeah and he heard the knocking on
the walls and his ceiling and heard that
it was moving around yeah you could
direct it to go to a certain place and
it would it would not from that place
yeah and he was a little he was bricked
here is a little freak he was freaked
they interviewed him he said then it
scared the hell out of him he told him
to call the cops
ya know so Peggy didn't call the cops um
which you know she didn't know what else
to do really I guess right so she called
the police they sent two officers out
and while the officers were there one of
them her name is Carolyn heaps
she said that she saw a chair in the
living room levitate off the floor and
move four feet by itself yeah I was at
four feet I didn't realize it was up
that far that's what she's asking she
said that's what she said but what's
interesting about this is the first time
a cop has gone on record she wrote that
down in her yes she filed an affidavit
that said as much and she said after she
saw that happen she checked the chair to
make sure there were no or anybody was
pulling it and she couldn't find
anything you can find interviews with
her see she was upset by what she saw
she was like yeah that's what I saw and
she also went on camera yes that's what
she saw she said she saw the chair moved
by herself she checked for trickery and
couldn't find that brave woman to write
that down
yeah probably especially in 1977 because
that was still kind of a no it would
probably think you were nuts if you said
that yeah now over time if I remember
correctly from the book more police
would show up every now and then and
actually watch little things happen and
it became quite a story around the
police house that you know the police
station they knew they knew about it
they knew about it yet but there was
nothing they could do no and no law was
being broken right and that's what the
cops said basically they were like you
know we're sorry this is happening to
you but you know no one's breaking any
laws and it's like it's not a police
matter stops moving around by something
we don't know what to do about that so
they couldn't do anything so the next
pengie pet book PEGI decided to call the
press
we have her help for help yeah so the
first time the first ones to come more
from the Daily Mirror that was a
reporter and a photographer the
photographer's name was grand Morris I
don't remember what the reporter's name
was yeah he's cool guy and you got
interviews with him yeah he's also in
the document and he's very sincere Sally
yeah how spooky it was yeah they did say
that the house was I mean when he came
he said the house was chaos he said
there was just little things flying
around marbles little toys stuff and
he's like everyone was freaking out and
screaming yeah you have to imagine that
the kids are in a pad
they're afraid they don't they think
that's ghosts and the the mother was
evidently kind of like paralyzed and in
fear and kind of in the state of
confusion I mean what do you do which I
guess you would if that started
happening in your household was that
help well you start you're seeing
something that people have told you your
whole life isn't true yeah yeah yeah it
is true yeah shits flying around
everywhere yeah
but Grand Morris the photographer from
The Daily Mirror said that like you
mentioned before that he got hit in the
head quite hard with a Lego brick no I
was trying take a photograph well he's
trying to take a photograph it just hit
him in the head and he and let the
dimple there mark yeah for several days
yeah they hit him with some force yeah
no and no one had been in the area where
the direction you know I don't believe
anyone have been in the direction that
it had been thrown from in the book he
said that they could see like in this
one part of the corner of the room four
or five Lego bricks jumping up and down
and then some of them went fly and then
it would just stop him immediately yeah
you know what it wasn't it wasn't a
constant movement of things it was like
sporadic things had moved for a few
seconds then stopped yeah a few minutes
later they would move again yeah and
then it would kind of heaven flow like a
typical poltergeist case where you might
have a lot of activity in the two hour
period then it trails off for three or
four hours five hours then it comes back
for a few hours it's like that ya know
also there are reports that the BBC sent
out a film crew as well and from some of
the reports I've read like I said it's
kind of hard to say because you know the
book was a guy that was there but you
know like a lot of stuff it's either
believers or it's like total skeptics
that think the whole thing was a fraud
right but reportedly the BBC said a film
crew out and they managed to capture
some things on camera but then after
they left they found that the insides of
their cameras like little pieces of it
were bent and that all of the tape had
been erased yeah typical yeah so almost
like it didn't want to be yeah folks
guys won't let you record that whatever
it is they're very shy
so I don't know if that's true but some
reports do say that that they that all
of their footage was erased and then
destroyed or destroyed so after all this
finally someone thought to contact I
believe it's one of the media people
someone thought to contact the Society
for psychical research from investigate
and they sent out Maurice grosse who was
you know one of their investigators
who'd also an electrical engineer he was
an inventor - yeah yeah that's true and
odd they said guy Lyon Playfair who was
an author and he had written a lot of
books on poltergeist phenomena was it
poltergeist phenomena I thought it might
have been the yeah I think that's why
they sent him out no but he was they
called him like a poltergeist expert yes
we need some other books he also wrote
he had written some books about that
psychic surgery oh right which he said a
lot of that's fake but he saw a few
cases of it when he was in Brazil that
he couldn't explain right that he can
actually see a hole into a person's body
and somebody reach into there and close
it back up that's weird
that's magic tricks but who knows yeah
palm like chicken guts and stuff I've
seen I've seen a person he saw one where
it looked like he could see into the
body cavity for a second weird unless it
was some kind of illusion yeah my bad
magician can do yeah but yeah so guy
Lyon Playfair was the one who would
eventually write the book about the case
called this house is haunted which we're
trying to plug because it's really
really good what he's not paying us or
anything we just really like okay so
when when the SPR got there Maurice
grosse said he also saw marbles and Lego
bricks flying around and that when you
picked them up they were hot which very
common yeah in poltergeist cases that's
that's reported a lot yeah um
although it didn't have it in mind no
but it but it doesn't instrument
believed 80 85 percent of cases that are
reported where objects fly around they
usually pick them up after and they're
warm or they're hot he also said that he
was standing by a table and there was a
t-shirt on the table and he saw the
t-shirt fly off by itself you know no
one was standing around it but him
yeah so the two of them Maurice grosse
and guile and playfair they pretty much
I don't think they lived with the family
they did sometimes I think sometimes
they stayed in shifts
yeah but they they were there for pretty
much the whole outbreak weren't they
yeah and it's 18 months right lasted
about 18 19 months no so they were
pretty much I mean at least one of them
or someone else from the meteor so like
that we're on site pretty much all the
time yeah they were they were they were
under observation yeah most all the time
so and kind of here's where it cuz a lot
of skeptics and I'll get sent away right
now a lot of skeptics are pretty much
sure that Janet Margaret were faking the
whole thing but I could have faked that
that's the thing though if they were
under observation all the time I don't
even think I don't even think a trained
magician could faker
some of the things I mean obviously yeah
I'd be pretty easy to fake you know hey
look over there I'm gonna throw a marble
or whatever but it's like some of this
[ __ ] was big like some of the like
Maurice grosse said Anne in Guilin
flavors book they said he saw furniture
like flipping over pulled a water heater
out of the wall it wasn't a water heater
it was a like an iron grate like the old
coal fireplaces they over there all
right yeah I saw a picture of it yeah
well bit was it now was that in Janet
Margaret's bedroom yeah and they said
the little girls weren't strong enough
even both of them together couldn't oh
yeah it was made of iron like if you
know like if anything no I I was in the
UK and 95 and some of the older houses
still had these but it yeah it's like an
iron grate like for their little
fireplaces oh yeah yanked it out of the
wall yanked it out of the wall and you
could see that he has photos of it in
the book you could see where it was
mounted twisted bent right and those two
little girls and the other yeah I don't
see how two little girls kind of do it
and I also don't see how they could flip
a couch over well and no one noticed and
a lot of the stuff that was moving and
and was witnessed moving was far away
from the girls yeah you know yeah thirty
feet or in other rooms yeah so no
there's no
yeah you couldn't fake it you couldn't
think that many people for that length
of time yeah good polo that's what I
mean in there and there were people
there all the time yeah they play little
tricks and Maurice grosse admitted that
every now and then they get bored and
they play a little trick and blame it on
the ghost but they got caught but they
got caught it made pretty much and then
the little tricks that the girls would
do when were things that the poltergeist
was not doing yeah I think one time they
one time they stole his tape recorder I
hid it somewhere right and then he was
like and then they were like we're gonna
blame them and goes hehehe right but
that but they caught he caught him yeah
they're little girls they're 13 or girls
that's what they're gonna do yeah and
they were getting a lot of attention
yeah out of this but so basically I mean
Graham Norris guile and playfair they
they saw furniture flipping over they
saw toys flying around they saw they
heard the knocking sounds up and down
the walls and on the ceiling
I think grandma's even reported little
fires starting spontaneously there were
also some reports that Janet had been
seen levitating yeah somebody outside on
the street so yeah there were two
neighbors I think one was quite a quit a
lollipop lady which what we would call a
crossing guard and she was outside and
she said that she saw Janet floating in
the window like laying on her back but
floating like up in the window yeah and
he's off from the street now she's up
from the street and another neighbor
said they saw that too right that was
walking by so you know I don't know how
how real that is now if you know
anything about the Enfield case you will
have seen probably the very famous
series of photographs yeah
you know speaking of levitation that
claim to show Janet being hurled out of
her bed right these were taken just for
some background grand Morris set up a
camera in the girls bedroom to take a
picture every few seconds like every
second or every half second or whatever
it was and so he got this series of
photographs that look like
Janet's like you know quote-unquote
flying off her back yeah that's not what
I think's happening yeah now if you see
all the photographs in tandem because
usually they only show
one of her like in the middle of the air
like freaking out or screaming or
whatever um if you see all the
photographs in tandem like the entire
series then it's pretty clear that she's
just jumping off the bed like it was a
trampoline yeah there's an explanation
for that though yeah I think she's kind
of going and she's in us in kind of a
fugue state yeah and the right
hemisphere birdbrains firing off pretty
you know and her booty caught it
she's subconsciously jumping out of bed
and she's thinking somebody else is
causing her to do it I almost kind of
like what you'd see from a kid who's
been undergoing what you'd call it like
a case of possession
yes bunch of involuntary movements right
that's what I think it is and she thinks
she's being thrown out but she's
actually jumping out yeah now how did
one of those photos are something very
interesting in it that people don't
point out you can see her and in one of
the photos I believe she's in bed or
either jumping up I don't remember
exactly what it was but you could see
that the curtain looks like it's
reaching over and grabbing the sheets
yeah and moving the sheets out of the
way yeah which is so weird I don't I
don't see how she could have faked that
because she wasn't touching it she
wasn't touching it no you can see the
sheet wrapping around the blanket and
moving the blank aside yeah seems to be
and then there's also speaking of the
levitation there's also a photo of her
laying in this really strange position
like on top of a dresser or something
like that and I think the investigators
claimed that she would kind of landed
there right in this kind of strange
vision of like draped over this dresser
I think she ended up there but I don't
think she landed on there yeah because
you know the if I remember correctly
she's on top of a record player yeah
that's right it's a record like a like a
cabinet style record and doesn't the
record player have a clear plastic lid
on it it looks like it does it's hard to
tell from the photo those weren't very
strong no she fell on that she probably
would have broken it yeah yeah because
is that one of those
I think she's just kind of in a trance
climbing around inside that and climbing
around inside the room yeah I'm gonna
stay of semi-consciousness
that's just what I think but I don't
know yeah with today's technology we
would know because you could set up a
good camera in there but in those days
they didn't really have video cameras
that were affordable yeah that's true
they just had what was it was just a
camera that was on the trigger when they
heard a noise they press a button and it
would take a photograph yeah or like I
said you could set it up stick a photo
every few she said every few seconds or
every half second or whatever I said
okay so speaking of trance I wanted to
go a little bit into one of the most
interesting aspects of this case was
which was that Janet's Janet's I don't
want to say possession because it wasn't
like a demon but it was almost like
something was talking through her yeah
pretty weird you know what I mean um so
have recordings of it yeah so actually
what I'm gonna do right now since we're
about the twenty five minute mark I'm
gonna take a break and then when we come
back we'll come back to the voice yeah
I'll I'll play some of the some of the
tape recordings that Maurice grosse did
of her talking in this weird voice and
we'll kind of discuss that a little bit
so we're gonna take a break and we'll be
back in a couple minutes if you're into
cosplay corsetry steampunk gothic or
rockabilly clothing shoes and
accessories then you must visit
subculture corsets and clothing either
online at www.haddadtoyota.com code
thirteen o'clock and receive a 10%
discount on your entire order and if
you're a full-figured girl don't worry
subculture carries sizes four through 4x
and they have men's clothing as well
that's subculture corsets calm and use
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount
go check out their website now
subculture corsets
or when traveling through Jacksonville
Florida stop in and check out their
store at the Avenues Mall podcast every
Friday took the top floor instead lesson
and the vodka Superchick pro-wrestling
in the hot spot featuring interviews
with an up-and-coming in this superstars
there are some people in suits lot of
works you can only hear them on project
entertainment the necro casting you're
on the podcast the breads horror and
heavy metal properties with a common
connection brought to you by house token
charmed Rock
max max smoking old Hades and bars real
Mordecai featuring interviews and more
with the stars of Maryland
the necro casting on Mondays on project
and entertainment network okay we're
back we're back the voice the voice okay
now the weirdest thing about this voice
according to Maurice grosse and
according to some other people that were
there he was recording he was trying to
you know he was he had recorded like
some of the knocking sounds he recorded
like the family's reactions when
something would move so sometimes you'd
have recordings of like something
banging and everybody going what was
that or you know what I mean he had also
recorded these kind of weird like I said
weird knocking sounds also the sound of
a dog barking yeah whenever a recording
of that do they do have a recording of
that um and they didn't have a dog the
Hodgins didn't have a dog their
neighbors did not have a dog so he
recorded dog barking now at some point
Murray said that he made an observation
he's like now if only this thing would
talk yeah man oh man shortly afterward
it started to tell a voice started
coming out of Janet yeah that was not
her voice right and when you read the
book you know he tells the whole story
of how it built up to this it's awesome
you got you just got me the book yeah
it's really creepy but what ended up
happening and like I said this is a very
controversial aspect of the case so I
think what I'm gonna do now I think I
have three little clips of her of her
voice yeah but you know what you have to
set up what the voice is talking about
okay the voice is talking it's the voice
of Bill yeah okay here okay now here's
the creepy thing about this now when
they have a little bit of video of her
like talking in that voice and it's
almost like her mouth is moving but kind
of not
yeah I had an overbite so it's hard to
see yeah she had a real big overbite
like she had real big the way her voice
sounds is pretty trippy and what the
voice says in this one recording is
quite yeah like at first she kind of
said like kind of childish things or
nonsensical things where she would swear
the investigators wearing and probably
old sod like that barking like a dog now
things like that making funny comments
yeah making like a little smartass
comments and this voice was like very
like I'm gonna play some of it later but
this voice it was very gruff and very
gravely it sound like an old man's voice
kinda and kind of no it sounds like an
old man's voice it does sound like a
man's voice and it would be I mean it
would it be impossible to fake no but I
don't I don't know how she could talk
like that for such a long time with a
tape tape her mouth shut and they put
water in her mouth and tape it shut and
that voice came out of her throat still
and the boys came out yeah yeah that
wasn't a mouse until they had they
brought in a specialist that was by
Jensen speech yeah and he couldn't
figure out how she did it yeah true so
pretty does that mean skeptics were
saying oh she's like a ventriloquist or
she was using that that upper fold
you know false vocal cords quite a quote
but here's the creepiest thing she said
this voice said he said his name was
Bill hmm he said he had come from the
graveyard down the road right yeah he
died he fell asleep and died downstairs
and share every went blonde yeah we went
wine first and then he said and then
Janet in the guise of Bill said I died
in a chair in the in the living room of
the house downstairs
I had a hemorrhage yeah I went blind
yeah but it's creepy it turned out that
there was a guy named Bill that died
yeah and here's the weirdest one
downstairs
they did some research the researchers
went and dug around who had lived in
this house before yeah
a man named bill Wilkins bill Wilkins
was dead obviously but his son was still
alive and his son said yeah my dad went
one and then he died of a brain
hemorrhage
in a chair in that corner of the room
just like she said and if that voice
sounded like him and that's and that
sounded like him talking well let's hear
okay so we're gonna play a couple ones
now and then we'll come
and talk about it tomorrow with you
there's ocean over though sixty-eight
nose
what do you got 69 totes kewl
sorry they can protect me you can omit
by gyrator
how peculiar
you should real
now how do exactly shoot you we can't
see you bill
hey sorry I didn't have to thank you God
for praying to God
so what you're saying is we don't get
rid of you are trying to come why can't
Janet Tsui
I'm invisible
you're invisible why are you invisible
my G
I dare to do it now I can't them to him
break out
and on
oh my
Oh
thank you
I
hello
I want you to tell me
well do you remember what happened to
you when you died just before you died
and just after you died
just law died by day
I'll employ
then I had an image and not been asleep
and our dog in a chair you know closer
downstairs okay
bizarre yeah pretty weird yeah and like
I said there's a lot of I mean if you
look around there's a lot of recordings
of her talking like that and like I said
I don't see how she could talk like that
for such a long time without messing her
throat out but the message was it from
the dead I don't think it was yeah I
think she made that voice why no she
made the voice because they had wrong
camera dad doing that voice I think
either one or two things either somehow
she psychically channeled the past or
gained access to what happened in the
past subconsciously and she made a fake
manifestation of this bill or she had
heard about Bill and the parents didn't
know that she knew about Bill and she
was subconsciously or consciously yeah I
don't know that some people some people
saw the are spk the moving objects and
they they believe that because they saw
that and then those same people who saw
that didn't really believe that a voice
yeah they thought that she was using
that voice to get more attention that
doesn't mean there wasn't a poltergeist
event going on because they saw the PK
the psychokinesis they saw that so I
don't know what to make of the voices
now it should be said that Janet said
that she said it felt like the voice was
coming from behind her yeah like there
was something behind her like talking
using her to talk it may because her
mouth did move may have been her
subconscious or her right hemisphere her
brain yeah may have been making that
voice may have been in control of that
voice yeah about her conscious willing
or conscious with what's good what's
good way to play without her consciously
wanting it maybe it just came on its own
right you know well like you said and I
think I think I think you mentioned this
on the mammoth mountain show that it's
kind of like a spiritual Tourette's
syndrome
like a Tourette syndrome right kind of
yeah but um so we're not sure like how
she knew about the guy but apparently
that was a real guy uh and and she said
things like I'm invisible or yeah she's
I'm a GH OS T she's yeah yeah yeah in
his voice it's pretty freaky even if you
think she's like faking it's pretty
freaky
but uh yeah but yeah that was a real guy
and she picked up on that somehow not
sure not sure how nobody's sure nobody's
sure and um okay so like I said this
phenomena went on for a very long time
people were in and out there was a huge
amount of media attention
um I should point out that other than
the girls
Janet Margaret were the focus Janet was
mostly the focus but her older sister
was kind of a focus too because I think
Margaret also talked in bills voice
sometimes
yeah they would report weird things like
god mr. Playfair he would be watching
over them where they were why they were
asleep
yeah and Janet would say something
strange in her sleep and then the sister
was would respond in a weird voice and
then sometimes both of them would say
the exact same thing at the same time
while they were asleep almost kind of
like there was something a link in
between them yeah but nobody knows
that's pretty enough yeah so I already
mentioned the one time where Janet and
Margaret had moved to maurices tape
reporter and said they were gonna blame
it on the goes now Janet and Margaret
were also caught one time bending spoons
physically bending spoons okay but
another time she bent a spoon just by
looking at it remember that that's in
the book oh is it okay that's in the
book but one time they were caught
bending bending them those ohms and some
skeptic have said well because they were
caught I think maybe two or three times
faking things then that means that
everything was faked not couldn't but I
don't know if it could have been I mean
there were so many witnesses some of the
phenomena was so dramatic and there were
so many witnesses those little girls
couldn't have done that and Janet has
said she does not give that many
interviews because apparently this is
not a happy this was not a happy time in
her life yeah
friendly woman but boy she is eerie she
is she's a little weird she's very eerie
there aren't view interviews with her I
think one of them she was shadowed like
in the dark but there are a couple of
her where you can see her face and yeah
she is a very weird woman she's in her
foot she's 46 47 now this guy over the
net she's older than me really yeah well
she was 11 in 1977 okay maybe that yeah
similar I think I mean because okay they
interviewed her she's been interviewed
recently because people were asking her
how she felt about the conjuring -
coming out being based on her story and
she was evidently not happy about it no
well it's not true cuz she said yeah
well will that - but she said also she
didn't really have a happy life at the
time or subsequently and she said it's
not really a period of her life she
likes to talk about that much and wants
to revisit but she has been on record as
saying all this time that even though
she admits that she and Margaret faked
quote unquote two percent of the
phenomena that the rest of it was
genuine I absolutely believed her
absolutely believer and we kind of want
to talk I don't remember if we brought
this up on the mammoth mountain show or
not we've talked about this before about
poltergeist activity about how sometimes
they catch the kids faking something
priming the pump and that's what you
call it so so kind of go into why you
think that might be probably the pump is
you know I didn't invent this term there
were other people that have noticed this
sometimes a poltergeist agent or the
poltergeist focus which is the kid who
is subconsciously manifesting this stuff
a new person will come into the
environment who hasn't seen it yet so
then all of a sudden splitting
performance anxiety on the the
poltergeist focus because they're afraid
that they're going to be ridicule or
afraid that they're gonna that the
poltergeist will be declared a fake and
they look like a fool so you end up
being under this performance anxiety
almost kind of like you're trying to I
like to say like you're in a men's room
trying to take a leak and there's a guy
standing next to you in the urinal
watching you yeah so what they'll do is
sometimes they'll fake something small
to get to take the pressure off
themselves and gain a little bit of
confidence in the the new visitor and
then once the pressures off of the kid
then the real phenomena starts to flow
right and that's been observed yeah and
I would say none of that really happened
in my case I don't remember faking
anything to get it going I didn't have
to you just kept going yeah and when
somebody new would show up into the
environment to see it the the phenomenon
would trail off it would vanish for a
while until until it with the
environment got more comfortable when
this me and the pressure wasn't there
and then all of a sudden it would start
doing it again yeah and then the new
person could see it so typically when a
new person comes to see a poltergeist
event the phenomena is going to stop for
a while yeah maybe an hour and Lori said
that when he first got there he didn't
see anything for a while yeah and it'll
start small yeah and then it'll build up
quickly yeah it should be noted to that
I mean Janet and Margaret and the and
the two boys as well they had just lost
their father they were not in a good
living situation and you know all of a
sudden particularly Maurice grosse and
guy Lyon Playfair who both very nice
guys yeah very and very fatherly or more
maybe more avuncular than fatherly but
they they were paying attention to the
girls they were at the house they were
taking care of them yeah so bring a food
and candy and yeah it's so kind of
presents
you know maybe them wanting to keep this
relationship up with the men you know
kept the phenomena going yeah and maybe
if they were afraid that it was stopping
or if it was afraid it was slowing down
they were afraid the men would leave
yeah so then they thought well maybe
we'll fake something
right you know just so they don't leave
us yeah yeah the conditions in the house
got better when guy yeah play fair and
Morris gross were there yeah cuz they
treated everybody nice they're nice guys
yeah I mean they were I mean they were
in and out of the house for you know a
long period of time so they you know
they kind of got on the table with the
family and they you know on a side note
the person I call this we work with
Steve Mehra knew Morris gross they were
the SVR together for a while yeah and it
should be noted too that Maurice grosse
he lost his own daughter
yeah I'll accident Roy and a lot of
people in the team was also Janet a lot
of people in the SVR thought that that
maybe it wasn't good from mr. gross or
Morris gross to be involved on that case
because he had just lost his daughter
and they were kind of suggesting that
maybe he was using this girl Janet as a
surrogate daughter because his daughter
his dead daughter's name was Jack was
just all set even though his daughter
was 18 when she died but I got no
motorcycle I think it's unfounded and I
also want to point out that the SPR was
mostly skeptics yeah
they didn't even go to see this thing
they just heard the accountant went no
that's not happening
they even go down there to go see yeah
very few of them did you know yeah those
are armchair skeptics yeah II don't
believe it go down there and debunk it
the turn and and James Randi went to
this case too
and he was there just for a few minutes
about an hour and then said nothing's
going on and left Magicians went there a
few Majin I think Milburn Christopher
went there he's a magician
and he thought the whole thing had been
faked but you have to be there for an
hour two hours three hours to get the
girls comfortable middle to start yeah
so been through you know like I said we
don't we don't know those skeptics think
it was all faked I don't know about that
but anyway it went on for a very long
time
18 months probably and then as a lot of
these do it kind of tapered off now it
should be noted that because there was
so much media attention around this case
it actually didn't do much
for the kids they all got bullied at
school yeah and picked on because they
were in all the papers
you know the front page of one paper at
a picture of Jana that's a devil girl on
it you know [ __ ] like you know the Brit
is but so so it wasn't a happy
experience for them and I think actually
are we at 40 minutes I'm gonna take a
second break now and then we'll come
back and kind of say what happens
subsequently like after that yeah and
we'll kind of wrap it up about this okay
all right so we'll be back in just a
second go to WWE and I'm a massage for
the Jenny Ashford author page okay so I
believe in a in a recent interview Janet
said she kind of credits I think they
did have a priest in to do a blessing or
something like that and evidently that
it didn't make the phenomena stop but it
diminished you know to a point where it
was no longer now like I said all the
kids were kind of bullied at school
because of the media attention and
things like that
now when Janet was 16 she left home and
she got married actually yeah desperate
to get out of that house he was all
desperate to get out at this point so
she left she got married which obviously
that didn't last cuz she was 16 years
old now she had a son and her son died
in his sleep when we was about 18 years
old Wow another sad thing is that one of
the younger brothers Johnny who was 10
when the phenomena started he died of
cancer when he was 14 weird
so not really I don't really know what
happened to Margaret or to the youngest
kid who Billy was the youngest kid but
they all kind of drifted I think Billy
ended up staying in the house until
Peggy Hodgson
died she died of breast cancer in 2003
now Billy and Peggy both said that there
was still some low-level paranormal
activity at the house up until the
mother died not anything super splashy
and this was after Janet and Margaret
had left home they said you know they
still heard knocking on occasion you
know and still stuff moving around a
little bit like to a lesser
I have an explanation for that though
yeah yeah the phenomenon is non-local
if the poltergeist focus thinks about a
certain place it could cause the
phenomenon to happen over there too
there's no maximum effective range yeah
so I don't know the the focus doesn't
need to be in the area yeah just in mm
yeah because if you can the focus can
move an object without touching it five
feet away what difference does it make
if that person's fifty miles away
yeah it's still supposedly impossible
and we saw that in a similar case that I
heard about the Rochdale poltergeist
which also took place in the UK although
it took place in the 90s who the person
that they thought was the focus she did
not actually have to be in the house she
could been across town and [ __ ] would
still happen in the house not to the
same extent like it would be lessened
run but she didn't have to be in the
house for [ __ ] that it's not
conventional physics you know whether or
not the focus is actually in that house
or not doesn't apply yeah okay so after
Peggy Hodgson died in 2003 and Billy
lived in the house for a while and then
he moved out so all the family dispersed
and a new family moved in to the house
it's on Green Street and Enfield I can't
remember I think it's 284 264 but it's
on Green Street at Enfield North London
and they moved into the house it was a
council owned house was a rental
property and they moved out now
apparently they claimed that they did
not know that this was the famous
Enfield poltergeist cuz this was many
years later I doubt that yeah they
claimed they didn't know when they moved
in but they said when they they lived in
the house they heard strange noises the
son a little kid claimed he saw the
apparition show
years like in his room and things like
that now they only lived there for two
months and then they moved out they said
they they didn't like it they said they
found out after they lived there for a
while that oh this was the famous and
that wiseass yeah I don't know I don't
know how you could not know how could
you not know I think they were trying to
make some make some bucks on a book or
something like that maybe get a show but
then another family moved in after and
that family they did not want their
identities they just said we don't want
any press we don't want any we want to
live here and leave us alone they didn't
notice anything no well they won't talk
to the media because they just didn't
want the circus well they're still there
then that means they didn't notice it
yeah I don't know if they're still there
or not
but yeah it should be noted that the
people that live there after claimed
that they also saw paranormal activity
occur but they said they didn't know it
was the famous Enfield house I don't
know I don't know I don't buy that
and I thought could you not know all the
neighbors knew yeah yeah you think like
I said it'd been a long time but who
knows
so just throwing that out there now so I
want to kind of put it because they've
made somebody there like I said there
are some documentaries from I guess the
documentary or the 80s from the yeah one
of the British one is really good yeah I
do like that with it's on bids all over
YouTube you can find it right but you
know and they also like I said they also
made a miniseries called the Enfield
haunting that was last year wasn't it
last year in the airport um that one was
weaker though it was okay like I said
the first two worries are really good
acting in it I liked a lot of the actors
in it and that and the child actors were
really good too but they really really
exaggerated yeah they exaggerated the
the relationship between Morris gross
and playfair's it's like they inflict
that was it there wasn't there those two
got along real well
yeah they made conflict between Maurice
Cruz and his wife which didn't exist um
and they also really exaggerated the
phenomena the phenomenon is I don't
think Janet ever claimed to see Bill Mel
she never saw but in the in the
miniseries you know he's almost like an
old man like a ghost like what bill bill
himself his his own voice coming out of
her
yeah yeah she never saw him no one ever
saw him no actually the neighbors said
that he thought he saw a man an
apparition of man when they were they
were out of the house remember the
family left the house okay but nobody
knows but never yeah he was the only one
that saw that yeah that could have just
been a trick of the light or something
like that or he might have been his
imagination running wild with him maybe
he saw something like a mist you know
like my blue haze and I saw something
like that maybe it was a psychic
impression in his head who knows but if
you really want to know the skinny get
the book yeah oh man this house is
haunted and it it covers aspects of it
that just you can't cover in the scope
of of a podcast or a or a but
documentary book it's good cuz it's just
like I mean I can see how people might
think it was like kind of portable slow
or whatever cuz it's not like a
Hollywood movie like a medieval or
anything like that it's just it's very
matter of fact it's very day-to-day this
is what we saw today this is what time
it was you know this is the test we
performed to make sure there was no
faking bloody blah so you know it's it's
I can see how people would think it was
Drive there used to you know super
exaggerated yeah but it gives them an
accurate but it sure what nice phenomena
is like yeah to deal with yeah because a
lot of it and we talked about this a
little bit under Mammoth Mountain show
to a lot of it is just kind of random
meaningless shyness repetition it
doesn't have a plot no per se though and
I think that's kind of where a lot of
movies no deeper meaning it's just the
whole thing's just an enigma yeah how is
it moving this why did it move that why
did it do that you know that kind of
stuff yeah there's a lot of it doesn't
mean [ __ ] no a lot of doesn't mean [ __ ]
no you don't want to read into what you
see it or you want to read into what's
happening you go crazy
try yeah true yeah scare yourself okay
so is there anything we forgot to
mention I don't think there's anything
we forgot to mention ah that you wanted
to kind of know touch on no I just
wanted to plug that book cuz that's a
classic
that's a it's it's the benchmark case I
would say it's probably the best
documented case in terms of the quality
of the writing and the size of that case
the scope of that case 18 months of it
yeah all those witnesses and there were
many many many witnesses yeah some of
them cops reporters yeah so that's the
case that should be the first case
anyone would read if they want to read
about poltergeist case yeah and what's
cool because it's not trapped into the
ghosts of ghost hunter mindset it's you
know the they're there they've been
basically kind of gets into the realm of
maybe science New Age advanced physics
it's something along the along that
lines power the mind even back in those
days they knew it was not in this case
they knew it wasn't some kind of a
visitation from beyond wasn't really the
dead it was a ghost of a living and it's
weird yeah weird but draw your own
conclusions just based on based on the
eyewitness yeah there's all kind of
different you know you can read the
total skeptic perspective who just said
oh the girls were faking the whole thing
or you know people were exaggerating or
seeing things they didn't understand
whatever or you know you can take the
other tack with the people that were
completely believers like I said I'm
kind of more inclined ibly people that
were there you know with some of the
stuff stuffed baked yeah admittedly some
of it was fixed well they weren't faking
it you're playing around they were
playing around with Moore's gross yeah
cuz like I said he almost became like an
uncle figure a dad yeah but and what
they were playing around with was
child's play compared to the actual
poltergeist phenomena what people
witnessed yeah you know you couldn't
think what was witnessed yeah okay so
that'll probably do it for this episode
as I said the audio only podcast were
now in the project entertainment network
if you uh if that's where you get your
download it's not on our project radio
and radio anymore and they also have a
bunch of other podcasts that are really
cool so you can check those out as well
and as always if you like our show
please find us on Facebook or Twitter or
our youtube channel which are all under
13 o'clock podcasts just search for that
and you'll find us and that'll probably
do it for this one second what we got
some cool new shirts that's right we got
some really cool yeah I thought you were
gonna keep that quiet until we made it
that's some really cool shirts the thing
is is that we made them because we
wanted them but we let you guys we'll
give you guys a shot Adam - because
they're really cool yeah real shirt yeah
at the moment there are five designs
it's 2 logo designs with one with our
famous logo a sign with us on it and the
other one with the clock on it
and we also have some that are based on
some of our past shows we have a real
society shirt that's very cool that's
Tom's favorite that's right okay so
that's based on our Nazi occultism show
yeah we also have a really cool satanic
panic one that looks very death metal
yeah yeah and you couldn't see but I
made them or hand them and also we have
one that was based on our serial
poisoners Jackie or slash show that's
kind of a poison yeah Victorian poison
themed that's kind of cool so if you
want to look at the shirts just go to
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock or follow
the links or yeah well actually can I
put a link no probably not not on the
YouTube video yeah but I'll I'll put one
in the show notes I'll do a video cuz
you know how YouTube won't let you post
links to that it's it's a nightmare so
but yeah if you get is that you know
everybody knows as all they make
t-shirts blood Ebola so we just have a
show on there called 13 o'clock and go
to all products and make sure you're
safe searches off because that's why
[ __ ] wasn't coming up moving but so
anyway hope you enjoyed episode 12 and
that's probably that right yeah kinda
sleepy sleepy yeah I don't know blaze
you yeah you are all right already
alright bye you guys
you